e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec des confidences qui m'empêche de
terminer monobras le grand bal mme laure
ne sera pas contente
c'est donc à elle que vous le destinez
c'est mon lot pour la laiterie de
bienfaisance qu'elle organise elle vient
le chercher aujourd'hui quoi mais on a
notre liberté aujourd'hui
oui monsieur nous la verrons et vous
promettez dû parler chatel promet doit
de son côté cause avec son père et si
tout se passe comme je le crois
avant trois semaines monsieur et madame
blood in her auront l'honneur et la joie
de faire part à leurs amis et
connaissances du mariage de monsieur
léon ce blondinet leur fils et bon fils
avec mademoiselle nord roberto que vous
êtes bonne et une belle mère doit être
deux fois bonne pour lutter contre le
préjugé ans en mariant il me semble que
mon père m'a donné une seule au puy que
tout ceci ne vous empêche pas de me
craint des abbayes oui maman
madame sur lui 2 f
prévenez mon père monsieur dans son
bureau en train de faire un coup de tête
un coup de tête
comment il écrit à ses locataires il
leur annonce qu'ils les augmente mon
père augmenter ses locataires à landon
c'est impossible
lui qui depuis 20 ans n'a jamais pu s'y
résoudre je l'ait décidé ce matin au
rond j'ai eu de la peine mais ce ne sont
pas des locataires me disent-ils ce sont
des amis et ses vingt ans d'amitié que
j'avais peur je reconnais bien là sans
un excellent que le malade est bien
sp
alors est ce fait c'est si tu crois que
c'est facile
j'ai rédigé un petit bouillon au köhler
a tué ben oui j'ai cherché à adoucir
monsieur monsieur à des gens dont on
reçoit l'argent ne plus 25 ans mais cher
monsieur au oui je vais l'écrire tout de
suite parce que je n'oublierai chez cher
monsieur
croyez bien que c'est le coeur navré que
je prends la plume pour vous écrire très
bien ce n'est pas un peu c'est non mais
des raisons dont vous apprécierez la
valeur quand je vous les aurez fait
connaître m'oblige à prendre une grave
détermination parfait après et bien
après c'est tout voilà j'en suis resté
là comment eh ben je leur annonce des
réseaux je venais pas de redonner à elle
n'avait pas mais maison ma maison est ce
qu'elle était quand je la leur est loué
je ne l'est pas a grandi je n'ai pas
embelli aux compères les les plafonds
sont noirs les serrures cris les
fenêtres à l'espace et des courants
d'air ce serait plutôt un aveu le
demande et de la diminution est logique
mais mon ami santos mais puisque tout
est mort non non non j'ai mes chances
ce cruel si c'est odieux ce que vous
voulez me faire faire là mon père n'ont
pas non plus et bientôt mettre à table
on genève aux siens quand je tenais une
pareille date à écrire mais il écrira
plus tard pour le terme proches au
bronze ça ça me donnera le temps de
chercher des raisons
vieux paris à propos tu sais comment
faire françois arrive aujourd'hui
d'elbeuf
j'ai fait préparer sa chambre je suis
sûr que mon oncle aux demandes des
locataires lui des réseaux mobiles très
ferme même un peu tu t'es - williams
notre ancien coach et il s'est brisé
tous les jours il nous verser dans le
fossé trois fois par semaine 10 les
jeunes mis à la porte a fait brutalement
maintenant c'est moi qui n'y est oui
mais je t'ai dit je ne veux plus le voir
dit pape et vous vous direz télécharger
sa question de détails et vous voulez en
effet remettre 100 francs par joseph au
moment de partir quoi joseph est un
bavard il faut aussi d'autres dont la
mort de mon père hier à la bourse il
courait de mauvais bruit sur votre
banquier monsieur tueur net on le dit
malade on découvre on ne saurait lui
porter ma carte malades dans ses
affaires vraiment on me fait beaucoup de
peine
d'autant plus qu'elle est chez lui trois
cent mille fois entendus courant oui
c'est vrai alors ce qu'ils voulaient
bien motorisé les retirer or comme ça
tout de suite
bonjour pourrait le blesser a cependant
il faudra le reprendre sa doucement sans
avoir l'air par 500 francs ça n'en
finira fort à propos
on m'a dit que monsieur mise à bromont
gauthier était venu ce matin qu il doit
repasser encore un des locataires qui
topaient avec des phrases
c'est un père de famille mais après tout
il me doit que 12 termes d'os terme
oui mais ils me donnent déjà contraint
la semaine dernière ils m'ont parlé à
coiffer trois paires de bottes continue
avait pas recommandé mais moi j'ai eu la
délicatesse de me les faire de nuit même
si bien que maintenant que la 60e paire
de bottes nomme dans ton jeu n'est ce
pas un rôle plus de votre four si vous
vous faisiez chaussée par lui il
s'acquitteraient plus vite
ils ne demandent qu'à travailler cet
homme là merci vous moulent à pied
d'éléphant
oui mais c'est solide et ça ne laisse
pas faire monsieur oui il y ait là
monsieur vise à bron il dit qu'il vient
pour son terme
tiens là vous voyez il m'apporte de
l'argent fait leur entrée
il ne faut pas comme ça se précise de
juger les gens en prennent à celui
d'avant frais au pardon il était là je
me suis madame je le veuille ou non je
prends mon café et je suis à vous tenez
asseyez vous aux jeunes et super fatigué
nouveau aux affaires reprennent tel un
peu haut mais ça fait monsieur savez je
suis pourtant laissé dire les verts mais
qu'est ce que vous faites là il est
passé qu'à location du terme ne sera pas
toujours la même chance
61e complètement
non mais je mise avant le goûter mise à
mort me suis mise à branges j'espère que
vous ne prendrez pas on ne baisse pas ce
que je vais vous dire mais je vous avoue
qu'aujourd'hui on
j'espérais un peu d'argent mais toi y'a
que non mais pas le tout mais un peu
mais ce n'est pas de ma faute mais c'est
plein dîner est certainement si elle
éprouvait car voyez-vous monsieur
blandine et je le disais ce matin même
encore à ma femme
il n'y a pas de plus grand bonheur au
monde que des pays à son terme
c'est très bien ces sentiments vous aux
normes et mesla sociaux ne va pas c'est
la guerre de l'amérique qu'il en est la
cause moi je n'y suis pour rien le fait
taire leurs et des collègues est pour
rien d'un côté tu ma femme elle est
malade et qui monte bien évident la
coqueluche ils tous monsieur est tous à
vous fendre les plafonds mais bhl avons
fait très attention
on prend garde les petits va tous et sur
le palier je vous emmerde 50 et quand
même pas allumer des feux dans la semino
pourquoi le saf messieurs avancer les
sur et la suie allez-vous faire à
monique monsieur deux fois par an alors
là c'est la mairie probablement non
monsieur propre à bonnart et si c'était
en effet dès votre bonté de nous faire
poser ou les petites et rate une petite
vanne tout bas le fatah a à permettez à
belge évidemment alors là vous vous me
demander des réparations moi monsieur
bois puis j'ai laissé 22 m messieurs ils
éclosent il est probant pour canosi
demander quoi que ce soit et si monsieur
unique 6
nous continuerons à ne pas allumer des
feux même par les plus grands froids non
non mais quand je serai pas dit ça ce
qui ne m'empêchera pas de faire ramoner
deux fois par an pourquoi moi je suis
entré par locataire
et je le fais là croyez bien monsieur
que si mon petit dernier il n'avait pas
là conclut c'est que ma femme elle
n'avait pas la fonction des poitrines
pauvres gens voyons une ventouse une
traduction ne doit pas être une course
très sérieux
un ballet s'est entendu ça y est
tranquille je vais écrire à mon
architecte à mon petit archipel merci
c'est égal
vous m'avez fait vous savez moi oui
monsieur oui vous avez eu l'air dé quoi
qu'il ne voulait pas payer mon père n'en
veulent pas de savourer ppri dames
céline lebrun vous êtes vous pourriez
qui s'est finie vous savez quatre années
en omettant mais qu'on a une fois malade
du courage tout ça s'arrangera n'ai
jamais lu des chances n'est jamais allé
adieu monsieur
il m'a écouté les segments faire d'autre
à faire de plus mais la sonata messieurs
bien je me permets de faire un servait à
monsieur que son pied
la grosse qui est à ses pas pour vous
augmentez qu'ils aient dit ça mais
annoncé cependant si ça prend des
proportions
pardon monsieur non on n'augmente pas
c'est mieux clients bien quelques
avec bien les avants c'est bien des
adieux bram lucie revoir madame
empoisonnant solide aux normes la grande
île
ils les passent le pape a dit allez du
point
monsieur sans la mairie belle ça
s'arrangera
je crois que j'étais un peu raide mais
je lui même a été un peu dur enfin avec
tout ça n'a pas donné un sou et tu lui a
promis d'aider par aso elle montre le
rapport à environ une heure à peu il
n'est ventouses
enfin ces gens là ne peuvent pas rester
sans feu
je leur loue de cheminée c'est pour
qu'elle marche peut-être logique de tame
par la location tu as une idée oui mais
oui mais ça c'est une autre question
non brouillon pas les questions de deux
choses l'une est le critère de monsieur
sont là à dubois à l'est 10,1
quel exactitude à portative de l'argent
à je ne sais pas mais ils ont une
réclamation à faire à monsieur bombe a
fait son entrée dans mon cabinet si tu
m'en crois tu accompagnes [ __ ] paix ont
volontiers oui oui j'aime mieux ça oui
parce que quand on est deux n'est ce pas
comme ça s'il me demande quelque chose
je dirais que cette regard tiburce
bonjour mon oncle bonjour les onze
maintenant alors que deviens-tu je ne
t'ai pas vue depuis le jour de notre foi
que je ne sentais pas dit si c'est
vraiment honteux mais vous savez les
occupations
je travaille beaucoup énormément papa
n'est pas arrivé non pas encore il me
l'abandon il m'a donné rendez vous ici
ah oui et ça ça tu ne serais pas venu oh
j'ai un peu grandi mais tout à l'heure
plusieurs personnes l'attendent
bon on tient compagnie à t'attend bien
alors c'est convenu 1,6 s'il veut
vraiment quelque chose moi je dirais que
cette première 18 pour
le travail est plus maintenant déjà fini
et voilà elle est encore fâché gentil ma
tante mais susceptible très susceptible
je demande à tout en noir à lacaune et
celle là bonjour ma part c'est un bon
garçon et voulez vous permettre voilà
c'est un oscar l'instant l'instant en
faisant ce travail dont la conduite
excellent les moeurs irréprochable
regard heureusement voilà comme il faut
mener les enfants et tout le monde va
bien et le boeuf roi la cotonnade lundi
mais la draperie se ranime nous finirons
par les battre à plate couture qui çà et
là les anglais gagnent montée 15
nouveaux métiers pour les vexer oui mon
frère il dans son cabinet je vais
chercher non non non ne le dérange pas
en cause en cour nous disons que tu
travailles oui papa
eh bien vous vous en doutez non mais je
ne crois que ce que je vois est-ce que
tu plais dit ah ben je n'ai pas encore
de cause mais mais je donne des leçons
de droits des répétitions et tu gagnes
de l'argent oui n'a pas combien
quand même 400 francs par mois c'est
gentil ferry ouais mais c'est que je ne
les ai pas sur moi je suis dit quand tu
auras deux économies je suis là on voit
les mois le oui n'a pas jeté promis 10 %
d'intérêts montant pourra jouer mais
n'ont encore rien vu ni plus tard plus
tard cette année je ne suis meublé à
turin demain matin voir ton mobilier et
j'ai acheté une montre en or avec la
chaîne une montre à paris mais c'est
inutile il ya des horloges et aussi je
te dis qu'ils ont raison ils ne vont pas
payer les portes et fenêtres lance à mon
père c'est l'usagé en fait je leur loue
une maison c'est pour que le puissant
très forte du football des jeunes michel
usage c'est bien sûr si tout le monde la
vie à elbeuf à la draperie ce rallye
alors tant mieux
eh bien mon oncle vous me reconnaissez
pas mal mais c'est léon veux tu n'avais
pas vu depuis deux ans et puis l'a
laissé pousser ses moustaches et ses
cheveux et tu l'a autorisé à quoi
laisser pousser ses moustaches essais
furent bafouées
est-ce que ça me regarde y'a tu fait bon
marché de ton de l'autorité le tyran
courte bien plus bas il me semble que
bien ils sont coupés et qu'est ce que tu
fais ce grand garçon à moustache il est
avocat je suis avocat comme son cousin
est ce qui plaît mais pas encore à ça il
ne fait donc pas les a votés abri
dacquoise occupe tu aimais tavel ils se
promènent leur farine dans le monde là
vous voyez vous de moratoire et puis il
m'aide à gérer des propriétés lama
procuration
ce vendéen fatigant de prospective ouais
je pose en principe qu'à 20 ans un jeune
homme est un homme et ne doit plus rien
coûté à ses parents écoutent ça toi papa
comment rien du tout quoi que tu qu'ils
vivent les voeux le maire a 20 ans et un
jour
je vais vous bénir rallie également j'ai
dit est un homme tire tout le faire et
il s'en est tiré il a pioché il donne
des leçons de droit j'ai des répétitions
enfin ils gagnent de l'argent
est ce vrai oui bah tu lui renvoie bien
quelques petites choses je place de
l'argent pour lui saint louis à ma fête
et saint louis au jour de l'an je les
lui bien sûr mon entreprise en lui
tenant compte des intérêts à 10% que je
replace encore ça lui fait une belle
jambe
il a bien tenté la première année de me
tirer quelques carottes
il écrivait des histoires romanesques
pour m'attendre et je ne me répondait
que d'euros chaque année à toi de tout
coeur et ils thème comment si m
même si oui papa tu vois je crois bien
il lui demande ce avec une trique et
tiens qu'est ce que tu me donnes par
mois est bien distincte d'une bonne
table nous ne comptons pas d'accord je
n'ai plus vingt neuf en fait je n'ai
plus d'argent je le dis à mon père est
la bonne route face à thouars y parlera
mais encore les bus darolles qui
abondaient à savoir lionel herri léon
c'est très raisonnable quand ce gaillard
est venu au monde lui ouvert un compte
le compte du news sais tu ce qui m'a
coûté depuis sa naissance non douze
mille fois les regarde moi le résultat
c'est pour rien tout compris tous deux
mille francs et 20 centimes de timbres
pour lui annoncer je lui enverrai plus
rien bah mon compliment
léonce m'en coûte au moins double 24
pigeons ça ça je ne le regrette pas je
me suis donné la brave garçon un avis
qui vous aiment et qui vous respect
comme le meilleur le plus doux le plus
irrésistible départ crise plus ma jambe
ce jour là même la chambre jaune leur
ministère étudiera avec moi nous pensons
la soirée ensemble
quel ennui c'est que j'ai ce soir une
leçon très importante à fabien bages y
tendance
j'irai de machette ou à faire
connaissance acteurs mobilier bon
maintenant je t'ai vu tu vas bien il a
dit n'avoir pas pareil c'est bon c'est
bon j'ai monté mon rôle en or vers les
11 et il embête en a pas que pour les
enfants
12h10 le franc un fils de 20 ans mon
autre élève les enfants au rap
ma foi moi j'aime mieux mettre le prix
bonjour plan d'ineffable s'est ouverte
avec un plus haut à rien revoit les
enfants viennent parler à moi et les on
s'est défoncé conduisant leurs
quand mitterrand lors j'étais amer je
crois qu'elle a quelque chose à lyon
bête elle est allée mais voyons voyons
parle
qu'as tu à dire tout bouleverser eh bien
voilà trois nuits que je n'ai pas fermé
l'oeil
la fameux aidant malades non mon ami
depuis un mois je suis sans nouvelles de
ma belle poule
comment tu avais le pauvre d'un navire
un bâtiment que j'attende amérique au
pourquoi il fêtait une devraient être
rares il y aurait à thouars depuis joue
je n'aurais pas après ça on le signale
pas encore alors il est temps que tard
ton bâtiment bah si c'est exact il y a
deux mois j'ai été avisé qu'il avait
réussi à forcer le blocus
mais peut-être at-il été rencontrés en
mer par la flotte américaine et ils
planquent tous les années le cap ils
peuvent tous mais à diable mais que les
assurés mais n'ont aucune compagnie d'un
volume garanti risque de guerre compte
en vendre ma cargaison j'ai pris des
engagements
j'ai une échéance très lourde et si
après demain midi je n'ai pas réalisé
une somme que je n'ai pas ce serait
peut-être forcée de suspendre mes
paiements bromont dieu et combien grande
combien de photos ne fallait une somme
énorme énorme j'ai fait flèche de tout
bois mais il me manque encore trente
mille francs à merci et tu m'as fait
peur mais je craignais de ne pas pouvoir
se les prêter
comment toi barbara bien non non non non
je ne veux pas pourquoi si mon avis on
n'arrive pas je ne suis pas sûr de
pouvoir talleyrand ballon sera le mérite
de cet été sur le pouvoir met la barre
haute en prêtaient la banque de france
mais c'est le nom que je te donnait
autrefois la pension danse au vietnam en
vieillissant on perd son petit nom on a
peur d'être ridicule mais quand on se
retrouve seul sans témoin avec son vieil
ami c'est si bon que ça fallait comme
autrefois dès lors il ya personne
appelle moi donc être mon nom enfin
voilà quel ami tu fais du docob petit
bon ben je vais consulter mon
portefeuille et après demain tu auras
ton affaire et combien tu m'as tu dis 50
ou trente mille francs 50 non je me
pendant cinq ans le palais les quotas
ton coton il arrivera il passera la
barre des américains on leur en passera
bien d'autres ont sa mairie qu'un hôtel
brave homme
les vieux amis n'y a que c'est solide et
je retourne au telegraph j'aurais
peut-être des nouvelles vous sortez
monsieur verta ray une course dans le
quartier gras je reviendrai chercher ma
fille c'est que j'aurais aimé vous
parler à moi cette écoute mon garçon ce
que j'ai à vous dire est très sérieux
oui mais ça ne fait rien pourvu que ce
soit court au très court parle chez
mademoiselle l'or au diable oui en effet
en effet c'est pas loin
j'espère réussir à me faire aimer des
laits mon rêve le plus cher serait de la
voir un jour devenir ma femme mon chien
léonce ma réponse sera net comme ta
demande tu es un bras bionique garçons
je t'aime tu ressembles à ton père et je
serais heureux bien heureux de t'avoir
pour genre or monsieur oui mais des
circonstances que je ne puisse expliquer
ne me permettent pas de donner une
réponse définitive avant huit jours
j'attendrai monsieur la hâte en effet
comme moi espère oui j'espère rich green
et espère
que vous êtes bon comment vous
travaillez à cet ouvrage il ne faut bien
puisque ce matin vous avez empêché
madame claudine et de le terminer à elle
vous a rapporté notre conversation
passez-moi la fois je vois là
mademoiselle je croyais être développés
il le quitta l'instant il va revenir je
viens d'avoir avec lui une conversation
une conversation sur quel sujet la soie
mademoiselle la voici
mais non je ne voulais demander pardon
je croyais que j'allais journée
aujourd'hui ça vaut
le ciel est d'une pureté voyants ne me
taquiner pas qu'avez vous dit à mon père
je lui ai parlé d'une demoiselle que
vous ne connaissez pas une demoiselle
que j'aime et que j'aimerai épousé écart
et bout de mon père il m'a dit que je
pouvais espérer
mais du moment que je ne la connais pas
[Musique]
vous les arrange du tout du tout du
toulouse mon oncle mademoiselle aubertin
que je vous présent à la moselle j'ai
fait des affaires avec votre père c'est
un travailleur et je vois que vous
teniez depuis vous avez raison moi
j'aime les gens qui travaillent c'est
pour moi qu'il a dit cela est gentil je
voudrais tu là comment avez-vous ça
c'est un sachet pour serrer les mouches
ou un halo pour yachts et bienfaisance
dans une place depuis eyl chimiques bien
sûr une trace
il connaît bien les y est vous allons
mon nom au moins vous savez j'ai souvent
pris ces petites machines jeu et n'est
jamais gagné d'une voix une paire de
pantoufles et contre au petit trot
porte-bonheur maintenant prenez vous
pour un franc alors donné un canton a
fait affaire avec le faire pendant 31
milles et vincent peillon valls 1 lyon a
mis 40
allez on se mets ton chapeau et cours
chez durandet mon agent de change
tu lui diras de me vendre 25 longs lyon
au mieux mais en fait on te presse un
truc qui arrivera avant la fin j'ai
parlé à cabrières bon non la demoiselle
vient tu tu vends des lions oui est ce
que tu crois à la baisse
moi non mais a besoin de 50 mille francs
la wii pour les fouetter un m un vieux
camarade vas-y tu deviens fou mais
pourquoi sarah 2000 francs et qu'est ce
que c'est que cet avis non je ne peux
pas le nommer quelqu'un trigon quelques
escrocs et on fera soit pour soit et toi
tu donnes qui unit peut-être au moins et
puis tu que je te dis que cette année me
au 28 e connaissait sa situation
paraissait pas besoin de la connaître sa
voix d'ici on sera à nous de faire
l'histoire bien vite bien épaisse un
mélodrame bien saignant tout cru et une
avaler comme une tasse de lait un pc
écoulés imbéciles imbéciles
tous croient tout hugo tour tout est
corrigée par un tassement dire le me
lève crochet par personne et quand il le
faut je suis aussi ferme que toi ce
matin encore j'ai secoué un locataire
ouais ouais comme tu sois les nourrit et
comme nous étions associés à ben arfa
mais il me semble que la saison est à
surveillance atelier des enfants comme
étant le plus facile à combler mais
qu'est ce que tu veux moi ça m'attriste
est de voir ces pauvres petits dépités
des visées des dvd des bobines elle
pendant dix heures par burhan ont senti
leur disait reposez-vous mes enfants le
travail et partant de santé avant tout
c'est possible mais vos baissait
je savais me faire obéir je savais me
faire écouter par blé goudé a tellement
que nous perdions 200 francs par le
poteau gauche je vais te renvoyer à
paris pourrait-on bon coeur tu as beau
dire les ouvriers mans regretté la ba
ouais ouais comme l'âne regrette sa
litière hollande françois hollande lui à
paris monsieur appris de la bouche
monsieur s'est retiré de l'association
je n'ai pas pris la mouche mais je
réfléchis je suis rentré en moi même et
j'ai convenu que je ne pouvais pas
continuer à engraisser de la fleur dépôt
jeudi rend très jolie anduze et des
phrases maintenant comme tous les gens
tiraient des affaires et ben moi j'ai
continué à progresser tout seul et au
lieu de vivoter comme toi avec 25 petit
mille livres de rentrer ça me suffit
pour tu iras loin oui tu iras loin avec
un choeur qui fit tous les côtés comme
un palier versées mais chacun son goût
mais je ne dîne pas avec plaisir quand
je sais qu'il ya près de moi des gens
qui ont faim de ballons aux dons à l'on
doit ce qu'on a le rapport
qu'est-ce qui a faim mais ceux qui n'ont
pas de quoi manger mais meyer derrière
pas plus tard qu'hier car vous ne savez
pas ça à elbeuf
j'ai rencontré rue de trévise apport au
diable qui n'avait pas mangé depuis
saint geours dit la vie non ce qui me
l'avouer péniblement les dix lui a donné
une bonne nature allemand est battue a
été refait damman on veut doit vivre un
jour sûrement mais quand on sait qu
latule essayait l'eau et b et c ie bas
il fallait lui hachémite de pentonville
amélioré vu quoi l'idrive rené tu les
connais tous trois y a tout dit quand il
a dit ça konami un vieil ami de trente
ans viennent vous confier ses chagrins
cet embarras au lieu de lui tendre la
main de le sauver je reconnais cela un
malin vous à cause dans la rue joseph
est décédé
enfin on n'a qu'un enfant un fils né
vingt ans relance eux sans ressources
sont un pavé de paris
et quand le pauvre petit diable humiliée
et frappée à affamer peut-être obéissant
à son instinct d'enfants se tourner vers
son père
réponse je la connais c'est laid on
porte 20 centimes à fond de contentieux
pas claire mais c'est vilain c'est laid
mais tu ne me ferait pas voir la fin que
tu n'es qu'un nom
j'aime mieux ne pas le dire parce que je
sais que ça fait de la peine mon avis
oui oui je suis dit hé bien jardiner
maintenant au café en attendant acda
femme et lui dire que je t'emmène bon
veux bien aller au café anglais parce
qu'on est dit le bien mais discutons
pour moi le monde se divise en deux
combats intimes d'un côté les gens qu'on
attrape n'habitons voire même pendant
six mois et je m'enflamme pas j'en suis
pour ce que j'ai dit les grands mots et
à sensiblerie ne sera jamais qu'un abc
bon appétit
et moi je vous dis que vous étés que
vous serez toujours un brave homme
automne et embrassez moi j'ai un petit
peu entendu oui continuez à coire le
bien continuer à le faire soyez du côté
de ce qu'on attrape c'est le bon quoi
qu'on nous dise à la bonne heure
que vous apporte la reconnaissance les
bienfaits n'est pas un placement me
barbe le port bleus au plus fâché que
françois son parti tenez moi je nourris
touladis oiseaux de nos quartiers oui je
leur jette pas tous les matins sur mon
balcon l'hiver j'écarte avec soin la
neige pour les préserver du froid l'été
je dispose des arbustes qui les
protègent contre le soleil et bien vous
voyez qu'il ment sacré du tout dès que
j'ouvre ma fenêtre les à grasse en
quelques années me donne des coups de
poing coups mais je ne leur demande pas
de reconnaissance
ils ne m'ont doivent pas ce sont des
créatures de dieu qui ont faim je suis
très heureuse de pouvoir les nourrir
vous avez vos petits oiseaux chacun a
les yeux chers petits tant que je
t'embrasse encore alors dans l'eau un
keeper maintenant adieu monsieur
blandine et continuer mais les petits
oiseaux
continuez continuez bon allons le mettre
à terre une lettre que ta femme m'a dit
tu donnais une lettre aux mon dieu oh
les pauvres gens yat il encore aller mal
à tu dis qu'on ne meurt pas de faim
et bah écoutes je m'adresse à vous
connaissant votre bon coeur
une carotte
je suis sans travail l'art est ce mon
père est aveugle
ma mère paralysé j'ai de plus trois
petits-enfants au berceau qui me réclame
du pain au berceau des pales de bonheur
nous laisserez-vous dans la peine vous
dans l'âme si généreuse simoneau rue du
contrat social
15e bissau 7e les chaînes à droite au
moment où de chez eux par une échelle
ces baromètres dans le mail à et la mer
paralysés parce qu'elle te laisser la
réponse chez le concierge
ah les pauvres gens au nom ne vendent
pas ces choses-là un fer avec une
échelle une amère paralysé oh et puis ce
sont mes petits oiseaux
chaque année quelques du genre ouais
c'est vrai tu n'étais pas là bon quoi tu
crois tu que 40 françois laurent ghilain
guy 40 francs tiens ce fait un tome 1
paris et qui a plein moon devrait dans
cette l'epo à londres on est pas soit je
veux te convaincre au moins une fois
qu'est ce que nous parions notre dîner
au café rogge alors le dans le manga ou
non je ne pourrais pas manger avec une
9e n'est pas pareil dans la poche allons
d'abord voir ces pauvres gens à l'on dit
mais c'est toi qui permet à l'échelle au
7e à droite ça me paraît
oh le malheureux ils ne croient même pas
comment ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si singulier tout de même monsieur qui
n'est pas encore levé son frère mais en
plus il paraît qu'ils s'en sont deux
délégués rapide et aux à votre ménage
n'est pas prêt c'est fini madame nous
avons pas de réveiller monsieur dort
encore
c'était mal a alors madame mais il est
rentré tard et il s'est promené dans sa
chambre une partie de l'élite
il aura pris du café salage il vous dira
monsieur je suis sorti je raison d'un
bien madame voyons vite dépêchons-nous
prudence merci je l'attendrai bercy
maintenant je ne vous demande pas
comment vous vous portez vous avez des
couleurs charmant ce matin
et
mais voilà elle est encore facile
gentille m'attend mais très susceptible
oh
et là bonjour les ans
j'attends papa passé le faste et encore
levé oui je le sais il a dîné hier soir
avec ton père et tout me porte à croire
que ces deux burgraves ont fortement
causer avec la veuve chapitre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça c'est un
bout de mon quartier pour dire qu'on
n'aime pas la bière ne fera donc
toujours aussi fou mais j'attends papa
et pourtant je n'ai pas envie de rire ce
matin qu'elle du chagrin
non j'ai douze mille francs de dettes
tous voient des dettes dame depuis deux
ans le papa m'a coupé les vivres
il a fallu faire appel au crédit public
et en ce moment il se fâche le crédit
public comment ils m'envoient les petits
carrés de papier avec des images dans le
coin du papier timbré hot poursuit sam
hanna plaire je ne sais pas comment ces
fripouilles on tape papa était à paris
il profite de la circonstance que
comptes-tu freire cepa de tellement un
conseil
tu n'as qu'à parties à prendre tout
avouer à ton nom cherche autre chose
la boîte à plat fait ce que je fais pas
ton père est le mien ça fait deux
ton père c'est un brave homme c'est une
caisse qui s'ouvre de temps en temps
comme toutes les caisses tandis que le
mien c'est une tirelire en fonte
s'emporte
pour l'ouvrir il faut la casser mais non
tu te trompes mon oncle françois les
corses un peu rugueuse mais c'est un
excellente ils t'aiment au fond mais
tout au fond d'ailleurs qui n'a pas
d'autre solution
voilà si je pouvais trouver avis et
heureux dit tu ne changerai pas de la
commission ou non ces choses-là se
traite de père à fils d'ailleurs faut
que je sorte lui et je te laisse à dieu
et bon courage
il fit le pousse à de l'eau chaude
joseph louis thouard si c'est vrai je
pense à toi mais je vais là je suis levé
de bonne heure et je me suis dit tiens
je vais aller embrasser papa mais c'est
pour ça que tu viens du sang vous oui à
pied à tiburce tu ne t'en remercie pas
moi mais mes pas beaucoup qu'on perd son
temps pour des bêtises pareilles est-il
aimable sais que j'ai un élève dans le
quartier va aussi tu es venu pour
affaires j'ai pensé hier une soirée
charmant et donné une leçon à tous
genres léa s'est aplatie communiqué très
très jolie de coire étude de votre mot
aplati comme une galette c'est très
spirituel même pas les courtisans mae
dispose est telle que si que c'était là
que tu vas voir mon dieu c'est un élève
tiens si je pouvais je suis plutôt un
client qui m'a fait priés de passer pour
me demander une consultation a payé par
le voici la sphère convient 25 francs
c'est gentil
voici la faire mon client est un fils de
famille oui un jeune homme charmant doux
honnête et qui aime bien son père à sa
il aime bien en fait non seulement il a
eu le malheur de faire des dettes des
dettes n'ont pas grand chose douze mille
francs 12 8 secondes et tu verras le
majeur a donc rien j'ai d'un minable
mais permettez il a pour exclure
un jeune homme qui a un père qui
appartient à une famille respectable et
qui se vautre dans la fange de l'emploi
le côté avec un misérable mais ça alors
là l'on est on l'a vu non oui c'est un
misérable je crois que le moment n'est
pas venu lui parler des douze miss
france c'est un tort et malheurs
t'arriver
et bien non mais je suis tranquille j'ai
rangé des travailleurs 1 il fait des
économies nombre d économie d les
petites économies
messieurs 200 m j'y allais voir
aujourd'hui à quelle heure alors le ton
du jeu les l'acceptent mais paul folie 1
soyez tranquilles ils aiment le chaabi
et les pieds de mouton je vais lui en
donnait sa disposera bien me fais ma
part et je l'aurais je lui présenterai
mon bilan au dessert adieu pas par mon
petit enfant aime bien mais je lui dis
fort voilà messieurs je déjeune en ville
vous le dirai oui monsieur bien sûr
je suis triste j'ai mal dormi
nous arrivons rue du contrat social 15
bis vilaine rue vilaine maison vilaine
aller j'étais ému
l'infortuné simoneau dijeaux concierge
avec attendrissement au cinquième la
porte à gauche
ça m'étonne la lettre disait au 7e
l'échelle à droite rapporte nous mentons
la clé était sur l'apport que je la
tourne sans bruit avec la discrétion de
la charité qui pénètre chez la misère
nous trouvons qui williams notre ancien
coach est celui que ma femme que celui
que tu dis j'ai chassé si rudement
hilton
attablé avec une nurse anglaise et six
bouteilles vides
pas le moindre père aveugle
j'avoue que ça m'a un peu cassée mais
bon y'a des gens qui vous qui vous
corrigerait du plaisir de faire le bien
mon frère françois triomphait rayonne
mais qu'est-ce que ça prouve que je suis
tombé sur qu'aucun il y a des petits
oiseaux qui donne des coups de bec
ce n'est pas une raison pour abandonner
les autres eh bien monsieur le fil entre
quoi au 7e laisser la loi h entrepris de
me laisser tranquille
j'ai payé un repas qu'il y avait des
travaux avancent bien
47 francs 50 centimes
voici la carte potage à la reine te
feras crevettes trois faons comme à
crevettes
je me range est très bon mais non plus
tu es sur la conduisant la même passion
me convient les restaurateurs comment tu
vas fait poser il me fut le prix de nous
qu'elle a mangé c'est une erreur voilà
c'est passé mais à ta place avant de
payer moi je vérifierai les additions
haut et le plus lent fermerait moussu
crémont ont dit ces choses là s'évapore
facilement offre à bonbons et la
soupçonner joseph maintenant un brave
garçon que chez moi puis depuis 19 mois
la mine
je suis du côté de ce qu'on attend adieu
je déjeune chez mon fils chose un garçon
sur auquel je confierai
2 4
c'est triste et un petit
je mange le petit salon brouillerait
l'autre vit à présent ce n'est pas par
méfiance c'est pour confondre mon frère
comment marquer à montjoire j'en suis
honteux ça vient jusque là que je vais
faire un lieu
ouais ouais là exactement cela
à cet accord le ciel vient vous a pas
faux pas alors je suis ma femme vous
entendais culinaire que madame est sorti
et les taux bas c'est bien mais d'abord
c'est bien c'est bien et c'est bon
monsieur examiner et c'est tout ce qui a
les meilleurs une qualité et une bonne
figure mais ça fait plaisir à regarder
ces nouveaux et tous vos dépenses bon
oui oui c'est ça paris brass encore un
bottier décidément c'est dans la journée
au vote il fut léonce ne tardera pas à
entrer si vous voulez la corde c'est que
c'est celui de mon fils et il a aussi
une bonne figure aux jolies chaussures
j'ai pris mes chattes examiner la
qualité c'est une faute de porto a fait
voilà de la fasch comment mes bottes et
data comparer monsieur
ni d'avancé et qu'elle laisse cuire sur
la race et ça c'est du bon dans la bâche
du vous devrez nouveau merci les noms
des deux qui est un coquin peut-être les
dieux merci messieurs merci merci on
passera chez vous merci mise avant
monsieur didon donner mal au pape
bah oui c'est une des stations bozouls à
madame au jeu n'est pas chose
aujourd'hui
ceci n'est rien et 27 cakin faudrait
devons renoncer à croire au boty on
croit déjà plus aux restaurateurs et ma
femme ma femme qui n'arrive pas
deux heures de bain
c'est bien extraordinaire faut dire que
je suis d'une bonne pâte fait la force
létale est venu ressortir entre et les
femmes plus jeunes que moi et jolie et
quand kate va le suppose qu'à m'en suis
jamais perçu des aides
elle achète des diamants des dentelles
pour plaire à qui il voue mais voilà que
mais voilà que je soupçonne ma femme à
présent au mais c'est cet animal de
françois qui me four ses idées dans la
tête on paie soit bien celle à l'anchois
si le montant de 25
mon ami jacques parlez moi aussi mon
père riba laisse-moi commencer les ans
tu ne sais pas une chose ton papier de
vol et le mien aussi
ces messieurs nous donne de la marche
vraiment au méjan figure t accepte tout
de confiance c'est une faute
avec ces gens là il faut se des pieds
c'est comme avec les restaurateurs sans
soldes de comptes des crevettes
quand on dit on ne manque pas de
crevettes et ils vous font payer doivent
retraite qui diable d'histoire me faites
vous là je te préviens des jeunes
tu peux encore se méfier tandis que moi
bon s'agit d'un projet dont j'ai déjà
parlé à ma mère
vers 2h30 de bain c'est bien étrange
j'ai mademoiselle ouverte alors ils
allaient charmante elle nourrit des
petits oiseaux
mon rêve serait de l'épouser et bed à
mon ami si c'est ton goût j'en ai touché
de molière à son père il m'a dit que je
pouvais espérer
comment son père le soutien possible
couasnon balle dans sa position
robin il me semble que la position de
schopperten l'ubaye et ruiner comment
j'en sais quelque chose
je dois lui prêtent les 50 mille francs
demain matin robin il s'agit sans doute
d'un embarras mentalement
je ne fonctionne pas ouvertes heures
c'est un ami mais fait une belle note et
des aspirations pour est en soi ne
manquerait pas de croire que monsieur
aubertin spéculent sur ton amour pour sa
fille au bon coin énorme ce n'est pas
moi c'est françois qui parle
la petite est jolie et il s'en sert
comme d'une amorce est bien vous si beau
si bienveillant non mon ami japonais les
sommes dues depuis hier soir
pouvez-vous parler ainsi d'aller la mi
mai mais ce n'est pas moi c'est françois
vérité mon père vous m'afflige et qu'est
ce que tu veux que je te dise que c'est
françois prêter de pareil sentiment il
famille que depuis mon enfance vous
m'avez appris à aimer à respecter mais
encore une fois c'est françois tané
qu'elle vous reconnais plus
[Musique]
un bonheur bah oui bah oui il a raison
mais aussi ce n'est pas ma faute
les bottines les croisettes et ma femme
ma femme qui ne revient pas trois heures
demain c'est invraisemblable c'est même
nocif pour elle non non non il ya
quelques jours
oui mais oui il ya quelque chose à tous
joseph joseph joseph on chatte foule
mais vous l'avez un coin a c'est vrai
moi j'encourage le commencement de
quelque chose le coup
[Musique]
c'est madame qui sonne j'ai oublié de
dire à monsieur qu'elle était rentré
depuis deux heures
[Musique]
voilà ce que j'appelle un joli des
jeunes à des huîtres du chef des pieds
de mouton as tu un régal et opère
embrasse moi petit commando je crois
qu'il a un peu trop posé avec la mafia
be tu m'as fait un déjeuner c'est mon
tour je paye le café
nous venons de le prendre je proposerais
bien de venir dîner mais j'ai pu faire
alors voilà on plus j'ai soif
tu crois peut-être que je t'aime fera
pas je suis sévère avec toi hein parce
que je ne t'en vois pas d'argent c'est
pour ton bien à me fait beaucoup de
peine et souvent si je m'écoutais
écoutez-vous papa non
il faut que tu trimes que tu connaisses
la peine le travail
battus dans le corps de tous les hommes
qui souhaitent dans le corps de tous les
hommes qui sont devenus remarquable ya
un morceau de vache enragée
mais ce plan il y en a a quelquefois de
mai je sois tranquille quand tu seras
s'élèvant quand tu seras riche je ne
refuserai plus rien vous êtes bien
bourrin hâtif tu veux tu crois peut-être
que je ne t'aime pas mais tu es tout
pour moi et si je travaille encore six
jeux conçus ma vie à fabriquer du drame
si je monte
quinze nouveaux métiers c'est pour
battre les anglais tient pour toi et
pour mecs et les enlever on voit avec
plaisir
je crois que le moment est venu du
parler des 12000 son papa il quoi qu'il
m'en coûte g j'examine et au mobilier si
gentil par exemple tu as trop de commode
à l'avenant avec 3a c'est trop je vais
vous dire c'est une occasion un lot de
commode oui j'ai été séduit par le bon
marché 1
à des gens qui m'ont dit oh qu'il est
beau match je ne tiens rien donné depuis
deux ans je vais te donner quelque chose
à moi j'ai donné mon épingle en diamant
aux papas ne va pas la perdre sur tu
vois un savon doux s'en faut sauf que
voilà trente ans que je le porte malheur
voulait qu'elle se détache un jeune je
ne prends le consoler aucun rôle à moi
renom près wallon ne remue pas comme ça
il suffit d'un beau mouvement rien à
l'étang de la lui donner les trois mêmes
je crois qu'il faut aborder la question
perds mon bon père malgré ma tête on se
sera rien je voulais vous parler de ce
malheureux jeune mon client qui a fait
douze mille francs de dettes c'est un
chenapan y est et on opère dans les
rangs l'afrique boom d'aller dormir un
peu mieux mais pas pareil rendez-vous à
6 heures au café l'angle mais il
n'existe plus avant alors devant la
porte
adieu trois gars là son départ est même
allé à tort de lui donner
ça lui apprendrait
à 6 heures au café noble 1
[Applaudissements]
pas moyen j'ai voulue par lui en parler
pendant le déjeuner mais mais mais ils
n'étaient pas suffisamment mûrs
d'un autre côté il ya de par le monde
une prise de corps qui trottinent après
moi si je pouvais auquel soif
ce sont les pieds de moutons ça ne passe
pas il me vient une idée violente
je vais écrire à l'huissier joseph
monsieur vous êtes apportez moi une
plume et de l'encré
voilà tout ce qu'il faut pour écrire
enfin méfaits comme chez lui voyons
monsieur il faut que la justice suive
son cours
papa est à paris c'est moi à son bras
nous nous promènerons tous les deux à
six heures devant la porte de l'ex café
lambelin et voilà comme ça ma passera
tout je n'aurais rien à dire et il
paiera il paiera et s'il allait me
laisser sous les plans de clichy pendant
quelques mois il me faudrait peu
d'argent pour mes petites dépenses
voyons 11 francs ouais
oh il me vient une idée l'oncle blandine
et je vais lui emprunter 20 ou 25 louis
allons d'abord faire porter ma lettre de
m
sophie prudence d'oublier moments chauds
bain enfin j'arrive de l'établissement
de bains madame et on m'a dit que vous
l'avez quittée depuis tout jeune
avez vous fait des erreurs mais je suis
votre où je ne vous ai pas vus j'étais
dans ma chambre double et makram les
scolaires et les voit pas manchot votre
complice à l'économie voit clair à
présent ses sorties fréquentes s'est
prolongée c'est ben c'est ben une longue
adresse livrables parce que voulez vous
dit vous avez une intrigue
il est impossible que vous n'ayez pas
notre idée mon pauvre ami en beauté mais
bon
evans en avez vous êtes-vous jolie
gwyneth vous coquette oui mais pas vous
ville est très coquette balle au bond
toutes les femmes le sont et voulait me
faire croire que depuis six ans que nous
sommes mariés
on ne vous a jamais fait la cour mais
nous allons dans ce serait honteux c'est
pourtant la vérité
donnez moi votre part le bonheur mais
mais ceci dit c'est un peu nous je veux
pas mal de ces lettres et lettres je
vous prie de quoi qu'il n'a jamais écrit
il ya j'en étais sûr mon dieu que je
suis maladroite son nom au madame le nom
du misérable ni vraiment oui c'est bien
c'est ces petits murs votre neveu qui
verse voilà
bonjour mon oncle il a l'air bien
disposés je vais l'enlever m'évanouir
belle course mon oncle j'ai une
confidence à vous faire moi aussi à son
don la cour à notre tante et comment qui
vous a dit elle même malheureux enfants
mais mais mais comment faire la cour à
sa tante
mais comment une idée aussi exorbitantes
tels que jamais dans ton cerveau mais
c'est mon club je venais ici tous les
jours
alors vous voyez ans tous les deux une
jeune femme un mari sur retour merci
elle n'a jamais voulu m'écouter ben je
l'espère bien après ça tu ne dirais pas
bonne moi ta parole d'honneur ma parole
d'honneur
ouais merci nous sommes prouve en rien
la journée dans l'escalier elle m'a
donné a soufflé sur chaque joue au mans
c'est bien c'est sûr ça vous c'est très
bien si c'est vrai mais qu'est ce que tu
lui les vues et moodie qu'enfin on donne
pas comme ça un soufflé un dans un
escalier
oui mais quoi vous savez on veut
plaisanter mais je n'ai pas tardé à
reconnaître ma faute
mon crime je ne suis méprisé mon oncle
je me suis méprisés à la bonne heure
mais il faut continuer une île il
s'adoucit mais alors pour pour mme
étourdir pour faire diversion à cette
passion criminelle je ne suis jetée dans
le désordre bien dans la dissipation pas
bien j'ai aimé une autre femme
parfait faut continuer une pauvre jeune
fille du peuple mais ça m'est égal je
suis obligé de soutenir de mon travail
de mes sueur de mes veines o o o donne
moi la main au lait de tout livre j'ai
des rohan
c'est une ouvrière dont le père est
aveugle
ah et la mer paralysé dès demain
naturellement ces sacrifices sont
épuisés mon petit pécule et je venais me
demander si c'était à l'effet de votre
bonté de me prêter 20 ou 25 louis vous
dont la est si généreuse
non
c'est inutile je la connais celle là
comment à toi tout coeur le motta pas
comment vous me refuser ou
considérablement ne voulait plus longue
le land in et vous vous êtes frotter
contre papa adieu l'ouverture au café
lambelin le sort en est jeté
san lameer paralysé chez tf1
eh bien mon ami avez vous vu votre neveu
oui mais vie je viens de cause et avec
lui il paraît que dans l'escalier tu lui
as donné non voyons si c'est vrai un
témoignage de ton affection
comment il a aussi dit je lui donnais un
soufflé au merci aux gens le savent
ça vient oui mais je n'étais pas fâché
de te l'entendre dire une seconde fois
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait mais dit
qu'enfin un on ne donne pas comme ça un
soufflet trans un escalier c'est qu'il
m'avait dit ray ne vous posez plus de
questions vilains jaloux qui vous suffit
de savoir que vous avez une femme fidèle
à ses devoirs et à son affection pour
vous mais tu peux pas le dire
tu me diras bonheur une autre fois c'est
bien drôle qu'elle ne me le dise pas oui
- croyants qui dure on vient me
l'enlever sous moi pour le conduire à
clichy comment à la présente clichy mais
elle est alors tous soumis à 12000 en
bas des dents ben ça tu le mets à 24000
à la comme le mien
by s'arrondit le contribuant çà il prend
du vente mais également je ne paierai
pas je ne paierai pas il restera en
prison toute sa vie plus calme amateurs
si je pouvais l'avoir lala sous la main
je vais chercher quoi bon on trouvera
car son roman au plafond on ne te
donnera pas ce soir l'établissement est
fermé les ports belges ont fait lui
ordonnera verbaux oui puisque je le fais
ton devoir lui écrire tout alu comme
soulage au voile
5 mars où il a vu le toit non mais il a
baissé juste
ils ont bu ne
or
ce sujet voir si je pouvais l'avoir mal
oui oui eh ben ça qu'on s'est lentement
qu'il faut savoir ouvrir les yeux et
fermé les eyrieux adieu rébus ou bon la
bourrique le pari mais c'est pas
possible
mais nous on joue les widgets
mais nous tous 2 4 5 ne serait pas
possible
jose aux mais je ne lui ai jamais refusé
de sucre quand je crois que françois
réseau aux fruits du côté de se
connaître à tort mais oui fut le
comportement ne se connaît pas pas
changé de ton parti
et pour commencer fermont et sérieux moi
à pareil que le monde est peuplé de
qu'aucun des domestiques les
restaurateurs les potiers les neveux et
amis les amis c'est aux pertes à plus
tard au cuss tin oo le fil un nom non
content de mon comté 50000 faut il
cherche orties monfils dans un mariage
ah ah mais je suis là je fais je vois
clair aujourd'hui oui oui mais j'étais
peut-être plus de relief
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est peut-être
ça fait que comptez-vous faire de ces
balles en jeu ne s'est pas madame fait
monsieur qui m'a dit les acheter mais
c'est le nom de toutes les factures de
l'année on a bien une autre idée
maintenant ce matin au point du jour il
m'a fait réveiller pour avoir mon livre
de dépenses et toutes les notes
détaillées de mamo 10 de mon bottier de
mon brodeur de toutes mes robes ça c'est
insupportable que fait monsieur il est
dans sa chambre il est plus jeune le
livre de madame et puis ma demande et
demi a aussi ce qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
je crois qu'il devient fou messieurs
voici les balles à sa carte il ya 30
halle juste et sortent de chez le
marchand ou ce n'est pas une raison
1 le marchand c'est l'ennemi bon palet
premier poney et tous les fournisseurs
qui viendront vous les perdrez comment
il faudra peser les fournisseurs mais
maintenant banon non leurs marchandises
ou de collants vous m'appellerez je veux
être là bien monsieur ce qui la fait pas
beau c'est défiant ses soupçons
on a mis la vie est une promenade up
j'ai reconnu que le chemin était mauvais
et je porte des lunettes va te rendre
malheureux pour des misères du tout j'en
ai pris mon parti
ceux-ci prague et j'éprouve à un plaisir
à cran à suivre à la trace toutes les
petites croix didry de mes semblables
j'étudie les animaux nuisibles
comment peux tu parler ainsi de gens
quittent estime qu' tous voient leur
maison home et l'araignée aussi ouvre
ses salons aux bonnes petites mouches
qui passe quand on va retomber
non ma voiture je serais bien heureux
mais bien heureux c'est quelqu'un venait
me demander un service à gt reconnaît
bien là oui je le refus serait
boucher comment avec 116 licenciés alité
comment ah je commence à comprendre le
plaisir qu'on éprouve à désobliger ses
contemporains c'est de la férocité non
c'est de la civilisation qu'un voilà ton
livre de dépenses
tu ne sais donc pas mon chapelier oui
ben est un voleur par exemple je viens
d'en acquérir la preuve il me compte
quatre touches à pau cette année et je
l'avais pris que deux c'est bien drôle à
un père de famille mais il y en a 2 vous
le doigt et deux pour les 11 à bien sûr
n'est certainement oui bon dans ce cas
là il n'y a rien à dire
le rap après une autre fois ses nuits à
ne trouve pas la clé d'armoires la
bassine jouent mal an rapporterait
immédiatement
je ne sais pas ce qu'est devenue la clé
du buffet la macif
vous me l'a rapporté immédiatement
briennon fier de venir
oui tu vas faire conserver toutes les
clés de la maison dans l'impasse si les
sucriers pouvait parler
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont te dirais qu'il
n'ya pas de meilleure place pour le blé
que la poche de son être à axione fait
appeler mon père oui
ce matin j'ai ajouté les yeux sur le
livre de tes nerfs et j ai relevé neuf
soit léonce dépenses diverses s'ancrant
où cela était passé nan je ne sais pas
depuis le temps que nous sommes au mois
d'octobre
ouais je pourrais encore 16 mai les
ondes se dépense diverses 150 apprend
pas beaucoup de dépenses diverses de mon
père non mais je ne te souviens pas mais
je ne serai pas fâché de savoir où va
cet argent
dorénavant tu veux je te donnerai 100
francs par mois oh non mais ça ne suffit
pas que l'enjeu membrane cela suffira à
doper monsieur oui c'est le boucher très
bien j'y mets alors ira à le boucher
irrité se trompera pas mais qu'est ce
que cela veut dire
je le reconnais plus ton père tu sais je
crois qu'il est malade alors gare aux
jeunes a protesté yeux qui attise fils
je vous présente un de monsieur qui sort
le prix mais restait yeux c'est égal et
l'a payé figurez vous que c'est un
billet du corps excusez moi un
fournisseur qui va t'en
maintenant nous sommes plus dans la rue
et que je ne crains plus les
attroupements
nous allons poser pour mon nom est né 11
à l'ouest où j
à veauche garnements brême
callon lui crédit sur la place eux se
trouvent dans les imbéciles qui accepte
sa signature
tu te feras adressées à des usuriers oh
non j'avais absolument besoin de 100
francs aux affaires pour manger dit l'un
d'entre eux fait je ne crois pas parle
après je jugerai on m'invite à un
marchand de meubles un brave et digne
homme qui m'offrit de me prêter cette
somme sans intérêt on attendait et il
limite une condition c'est que je lui
achèterai 3 commode qui gêné dans son
magasin derrière et les commerces
il me fit souscrire une lettre de change
de 4000 francs tu m'as dit de 2000 les
commodes 2000 francs 3 comme quand notre
sens très cher à paris quand on en a pas
besoin
bon l'échéance arrive à ce jeu ne paient
pas bah il fallait l'écrire mais c'est
ce que je fis ou me répondit tu feras je
la connaissais la table tout coeur le
marchand de meubles devenait intraitable
c'est alors que je fis la connaissance
d'un marchand de challes bien un homme
très rond il me conta tout de suite mais
4000 francs sans intérêt il me dit
seulement qu'il serait bien naze que je
lui achetais cash mais bof bof je n'en
avais pas j consentis et je lui
souscrivit une lettre de change de 8000
francs malheureux 4000 francs de
cachemire en veillant à tous les prix
celui-là est superbe
tu me donneras nous verrons quand tu te
mariera à le placer dans sa corbeille
c'est trop juste voici
il n'exerce une reconnaissance du monde
pied tout misé ratu mais au moins tu y
étais vraiment terre les jo j'ai faim
coiffe un matin et elles sont des
répétitions je vous ait trompé je n'en
avais pas alors de quoi tu vécu depuis
deux ans c'est un il y a des soir je me
suis couché je buvais macabre mon dieu
mon pauvre enfant mon petit tiburce sac
à main comme il est maire
tiburce papa si c'est bien assez bien
les ondes être pas m'avoir écrit mon
oncle pourrait-on se procurer tout de
suite 3 ou 4 10 steaks et une bouteille
de bordeaux très facilement si vous
voulez passer un seul à manger josep à
mousser en nombre - non je n'ai pas faim
moi non plus léger possible le document
je veux que tu te fasses pour vous obéit
de me voir je veux te regarder manger
pour enfants
comme tout cela est mon dieu que tout
cela et me viens viens me retourner
qui va tout mais maintenant je deviens
de peser le boucher 7 grammes de moins
et 2 grosso sans compter le papier
d'emballage en un père de famille assez
bien trop mon père il est 11h30 oui eh
bien c'est à midi que monsieur bertin
doit envoyer prendrait 50 mille francs
avait promis lui prêter à fait ma foi
aurait pu penser plus comment ben oui ma
parole au bon heureusement qu'il s'agit
d'un vieil ami et votre coeur j'en suis
sûr vous y ont rendu l'âme et moi ou
voit plus le coeur à bonal
il ne faut pas trop compter sur cet
organe l'a1 et moi j'écoute mon père que
je compte sur vous et sur la table à
dieu oui privé et merci ridoret
un enfant je suis fâché le voir si ma
bannette
et voilà ces cinq ans et demi la france
en bons billets de banque et ils sont en
tout neuf
1 2 3 c'est embêtant prêter des billets
neufs
on vous en rendez vieux
déchirée malpropre 4 5 6 quand on vous
les rangs c'est oui neuf aux pertes à
nous les rendre à jamais c'est un homme
coup les 10 son avenir n'est pas assurée
range les hommes leur école ont pris
fond la pire pape l'actif vigilant
audacieux les américains c'est tout je
n'étais faut que je recommence à chaud
c'est drôle comme ça et chose de prêter
de l'argent quoi est d'abord partie de
la ville il me l'a dit un mais je n'ai
pas vu six sets vite cette personne ne
le sauvera pas et elle servira à
rembourser les créanciers disque qui
sonne encore de lui onze et deux mois 12
s'il veut consulter françois o pourquoi
bon mais après coup je le suis pas tenue
de rembourser les bateaux de ce monsieur
moi j'ai une famille une femme des
enfants des enfants et je ré
compromettre leur part leur patrimoine
non non non mais bigs
mon ami donc mon cher ami
une catastrophe imprévue m'empêche de te
prêter les 50 mille francs que je
t'avais prenons
c'est pour moi un chagrin dont je ne me
consolerai jamais
à toi de tout coeur
ça se met toujours quand on refuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors monsieur a sonné oui cette fois
lettre à son timbre est tout de suite
y at il une réponse vous n'attendrez pas
aller à monsieur je prends mon chapeau
que j'y vais tout de suite
oh
oh que c'est mal
oh que c'est miles au que ces eaux que
c'est aux que ses mains
[Musique]
ce que je viens de faire là c'est
méchant c'est cruel
un vieil ami joseph joseph losey au
bâton puis attend fine c'est bien fait
c'est bien fait après tout je deviens
coquin oui je je je mens dur si je me
fais me classe comme les autres lui mon
ami quel choix quel bonheur je suis
sauvé
comment on la vire la belle poule il est
war à battre et ce matin je viens de
recevoir la nouvelle ils ne cassent des
ondes magnifique une fortune j'embrasse
s'apprécier management vient d'annoncer
cette bonne nouvelle et te dire que je
n'ai plus besoin de tes 50 mille francs
mais si j'avais su mais vois-tu blandine
aignan est mormon vieillit de l'histoire
ne lui seul revers de fortune nous
éprouve quelques fois bien cruellement
mais ils ont un bon côté celui de nous
faire connaître nos vrais amis
si jamais entendu ma lettre jamais
jamais je n'oublierai ce que tu as fait
pour moi nous ne parlons plus de ça et
nos enfants nos chers enfants vont-ils
être heureux tu sais qui est relayons ce
m'a demandé la main de ma fille la
bibine
mais dans la situation où je me trouvais
mon avis reperdu j'étais en ruine et je
n'ai pu lui répondre qu'une chose at en
effet comme moi espère mais comment
votre conscience je ne pouvais pas
donner à ton fils une fille s'endort
mais aujourd'hui je suis riche plus
risque quoi peut-être ai-je et leur
monsieur de vous demander la main de
votre fille sans omettre peureux
certainement mal est si je pouvais
qu'est ce que tu as noir talent et non
mais elle est inutile du tout je veux
savoir ce que tu m'écris venons
oh mon dieu ça y est que lui dire une
catastrophe imprévue mon pauvre ami ce
qu'on dit et dont vrai je n'osais pas
tant par les badauds un bon banquier
monsieur tourneppe ces compagnies là ils
sont en fuite
oh mon dieu quand tu ne laisseras tu dis
là tu ne le savais pas mais non mais
alors là cadre de l'acaata la
catastrophe
la quête à bbb oui la caf aux bons
sentiments ne sait rien encore réduite
mais j j'ai trois cent mille roches et
des mains je suis ruiné au mon ami mon
pauvre ami
aurel courtois si dévouée rivaux mais
sois tranquille du courage nous nous
reverrons coubertin mais où va-t-il
mais il me plante là les amis après le
service que j'ai été sur le point de lui
rendre
il me plante là haut à les amis quant à
celui là il va me demander son comble
mais l'accord est celle là mais pour
avoir un point certes et bigorre oui
vous l'aurez sanaa comme audrey pas
monsieur dû me garder pour rien quant à
la nourriture je ne suis pas difficile
comment non vous voulez me servir
s'engage vous atteindre peine de quitter
monsieur mais c'est qu'il pleure
réellement un si bon d'être il année
dernière quand j'ai été malade a été
mais chercher ici dit sirop de gaulle
lui-même
[Rires]
aujourd'hui joseph ça me fait de la
peine d'être ruinés mais de notre côté
ça me fait plaisir mais la caisse qui
vient au madame monsieur vermine et
quinet et vous la confiance l'appétit
son ami mon verre je comprends
maintenant ses inquiétudes et les
réformes que tu voulais introduit à dans
notre dépend elle s'en serait ce qui
l'aurait jamais pesé le boucher mon ami
j'ai des diamants dit d'antenne ou les
vendront aux eaux
elle veut vendre ses diamants et ce
matin encore au mot frier 100 francs par
mois
tu n'en veux pas à mon père je suis
jeune je travaillerai c'est à moi
aujourd'hui de pourvoir à vos besoins
à mi hauteur aussi fort entre nos deux
coeurs que ne se sentira pas l'effroi de
la misère d'entre nous croient guère aux
eaux continue aimé continuer si vous
saviez le bien que vous me faites à la
femme et la famille
il ne faut croire qu'à ça est un peu aux
domestiques
merci joseph merci ceci vous absous près
de kouadio buissière
hier notre vie le sucre de rien le par
le brutal au billet messieurs monsieur
tiburce il s'est fait trois canards
avant et je l'accusé aux jo se tenait
j'osais je les ai prises par méfiance 1
c'était pour les faire arranger fa non
monsieur je viens d'apprendre que je
vous apporte des mandats comme moi ne
presse sports rappelle quand vous
utilisez si vous pouviez atteint
maintenant
blizzard a fait son cuir n'est peut-être
pas de première qualité mais son coeur
en lots soccer mise à brûler les données
mises à mal ces besoins de bande à
lucien limousin fait déplumer cependant
mais je tenais
voilà vous monsieur poireau savons c'est
l'effet le plus à mes débuts pour vous
c'est quoi ces sublimes
il faut donc croire aussi au beau pied
est bien devant le belge willy attend là
je l'avais prévu tu te seras des ces
derniers que manier un bourbon oncle
c'est comme ça qu'une console tu vas
avoir des difficultés les problèmes mais
je te recommande tieger street avant car
si c'est tout ce qu'ils offrent à temps
papa oui si je ne suis pas complètement
avocats devant l'argent de ma thèse je
les mange est bonne
si c'est pour manger tu as bien nous dit
non à sa tenue prenez-ça une épingle en
diamant sens à vos douces en france
c'est tout ce que j'ai si j'avais besoin
[Musique]
les neveux les neuf que ce pont
il n'y a que les frères on voit là le
bien il écrit tranquillement son
courrier bien
since imbéciles quoi un acte de
l'association commence avec moi il faut
que les gens fassent apporte une ville
que tu l'a perdue ou peut se réparer
monsieur bertin ya six mois certes
poteau un acte une association encore du
stade et j'ai dit qu'il ne reviendrait
plus facile qui attend que tu veuilles
bien demander sa main ça ne se peut plus
les ronces n'a pas de toutes parts dont
il a pour dote les 50 mille francs que
tu voulais me prêter le colloque le
savoir et parlons-en au contraire tu
allais lui constitue comme apport au
monde que les hommes sont beaucoup de
ces deux forums priverait de priver en
gros pour mon petit mon dieu que les
femmes son bord
d'ailleurs tout n'est peut-être pas
désespérer ton banquier monsieur thual
eps vient d'être arrêté à la frontière
de belgique monsieur tournai mais oui
que c'est bien les trois cent mille
francs mais ne sont plus chez lui
muni de votre procuration j'ai retiré un
van thiel sont aujourd'hui à la bande à
bord mais d'abord je vous rendrai au
total sans préciser le brésil où joseph
joseph je double vos gardes pour toi tu
pourras des diamants lui d'accord à
cabriolet et je suis content c'est à
dire que non mais mes enfants parce que
je fais une chose pour que je ne vous
dirai jamais aux aguets
je suis inquiet je suis un gars te dis
un misérable j'ai douté j'ai tout et de
l'amitié de ma femme de mon dossier
non monsieur
j'ai douté plus qu'à ferrand qu'elle a à
proposer manger des crevettes m'en
souviens là tu vois c'est bien fait
enfin j'étais devenue ho je suis devenu
méchant soupçonné
je ne croyais plus à nos petits oiseaux
vous deviez des magouilles mais je suis
bien corrigé à présent aussi qu'on
vienne me demander un service
combien la vente rentes et de l'argent
et on verra alors inventif urbain oui
mais c'est bien pour lui que je dis ça
ce brave garçon
voyez-vous mes enfants j'ai bien
réfléchi je connais le monde à présente
depuis on ne peut plus cinq minutes et
bien dans la vie pour être heureux il
est petit il est possible en supposant
qu'il y ait quelques hommes qui ne soit
pas complètement parfaite non mais ça
c'est une supposition à eybens dans la
vie pour être heureux il faut savoir
faire deux choses
ouvrir les yeux et ferme les airs et non
fermé les yeux et ouvrir les mains
[Applaudissements]
la pièce les petits oiseaux que nous
avons eu le plaisir de jouer ce soir
devant vous êtes deux gènes labiche et
de la cour
[Applaudissements]
le décor est de jean-pierre clech
les costumes de donald cardwell
la mise en scène de rené dupuy
[Applaudissements]
avec andrée petelle
max-andré
[Applaudissements]
brigitte chamarande
philippe ogouz
[Applaudissements]
hier des pailles
gérard cros
[Applaudissements]
rené dupuy
isabelle dubi
[Applaudissements]
georges beller
marthe mercadier
oui henri tisot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]